find the circumference of a circle that
has a radius of 12 inches so if i were
to draw the circle right over here
the radius so that's the center of the
circle the radius here is 12 inches we
need to figure out what's the distance
to go around the circle the distance of
the if if i were to make a string here
and to go actually around just like this
so the first thing to realize is that
there's a very special number called pi
that we use when we deal with circles
and pi is actually defined as the ratio
between the circumference and the
diameter of a circle this is one of the
ways that one can define pi and pi is
denoted by the greek letter pi
and this is and we can keep adding
digits to it but it's
3.14159 and some people make sport out
of trying to memorize as many digits of
pi as possible but it's one of those
weird wacky numbers that show up
throughout nature and it just keeps on
repeating for actually it keeps on going
on forever but it does not repeat which
is crazy i mean maybe you know the why
why wasn't the ratio discomforts of the
diameter of circles three it's just you
know instead it's this kind of wacky
wacky wacky number but with that out of
the way through this definition of what
pi is we actually get a formula for if
you know pi and if you know one of these
two things you can get the other one so
if you know the diameter and you want to
come out the circumference you multiply
both sides of this really this
definition of pi you multiply both sides
by d
and you get c
is equal to pi
times d
or another way to think about it because
the diameter of a circle is 2 radii the
length of a diameter is two times the
length of the radius you can replace
your diameter with two times the radius
and so that gives you and this is kind
of a famous formula
c is equal to or circumference is equal
to 2 pi 2 pi r or here it's pi times 2
times r you switch them around you get 2
pi r
and we just apply that
our radius is 12 inches so this is going
to be 12 we need to calculate the
circumference our circumference is going
to be 2 times pi times 12 that is 24
times pi if we want the exact number
remember pi is an actual number it's
3.14159 keeps on going on and on on
forever let's actually get our
calculator out
so we can multiply
we can multiply 24 and then we have to
find pi here pi is right in yellow there
so i press second and that right over
there 24 pi which literally just means
24 times the number pi which is 24 times
3.14159 on and on and on
and we get 75.398
so depending they haven't told us
exactly exactly how much precision they
want over here but if we round to the
nearest actually even if we round to the
hundreds place we get
75.40 so i'll go with that so this is
equal to approximately equal to 75.40
and we're done